um representative Sullivan you recognize
oh sorry opening the executive session
on House Bill 17 FN I recognized
representative Sullivan for a motion I
move interim study all right the motion
is interim study seconded by
representative
lir you're recognized to uh to speak to
your motion um we've actually had quite
a bit of discussion about this uh topic
and um remote work while it's not a New
Concept by any means is it certainly uh
exploded with the pandemic um and you
know all of the sudden people who were
office dwellers became
um remote workers and um no thought was
given to it um it just happened and
um since the pandemic we've all
witnessed that a lot of these remote
workers remained remote workers um a lot
of companies decided that uh they didn't
want to pay for an office um some of
them decided that uh they're getting
more productivity out of someone working
for home um but uh What uh the sponsor
of this bill represent McKenzie is uh
suggested is that you know if you you
are working from home that home is a
workplace
and I guess the question is um what
exactly does that
mean um
and rep McKenzie made some um uh some
attempts he actually work on a couple of
U amendments um but in the end I think
we really need to pose that question
what exactly does it mean when your home
becomes a
workplace um I mean one of the posters
that is expected to be in all um uh um
workplaces is one dealing with toxic
materials they all must be inventoried
well does that mean someone's got to go
through my garage in inventory all of
the fertilizers and pesticides and the
stuff that is technically in the work
workplace um but having nothing to do
with my work um
so I would suggest I think just we we
are suggesting that this is worth
thinking about talking about um and
seeing if there is appropriate
legislation that will um address the
complexities and uniqueness of U remote
work so that's why I'm moved to interim
I will tell you representative Sant I
got a an email two days ago from someone
asking me regarding workers compensation
and remote workers and the question was
posed do you have to have it posted at
someone's home all of the labor
department mandated
posters you know one would think yes not
sure you can force someone to put a
poster on their wall for themselves but
at least it's something we can
discuss
to that to that point uh I did ask the
Department of Labor toh give us an
opinion relative to posters uh because
you know as cool as it might be to put
posters all over your house um there is
uh uh it is acceptable um and they they
could explain themselves but it is
acceptable do them electronically or
provide some kind of portal where people
can have access to so that that would
kind of take that um away
seeing no other hands we have a motion
on the floor it's been second we've had
the discussion if you are in favor of
interim study you signify by saying yes
if you're opposed no madame clerk me
call the
role Vice chair seaworth
yes rep avalani yes rep Prout yes rep
c yes rep nder yes rep Mason yes rep
kcom yes rep drgo yes rep Granger
yes ranking D Sullivan yes R
barudi rep Cahill yes rep hackin
Phillips yes rep Susi yes Rett bushard
yes Rett McKenzie yes the clerk votes
yes repair yes rep stab yes Mr chair yes
20 to
zero any objection consent
agenda seeing none thank
you next bill is House Bill
1051 relative to prohibiting certain
deductions from wages of restaurant
employees representative Drago you're
recognized for a
motion I move itl motion on the floor is
itl seconded by representative uh ret KC
sorry your recognized to speak to your
motion I don't think there's really much
to say uh the sponsor came and said that
this is already in statute so there's
really no reason to have second law to
duplicate the first and for that reason
motion seeing no other
hands motion's been made and seconded
we've had a
discussion Madam clerk would you call
the role on House Bill 1051 if you're in
favor of itl you'll be signified by
saying yes oppose
no when you have the
chance Vice chair seaworth yes rep
avalani yes rep Prout yes rep c yes rep
ner yes rep Mason yes rep pcam yes rep
dgo yes rep Granger yes ranking D
Sullivan yes rep Rudy yes rep
kill yes rep hacken Phillips yes rep
Susi yes rep bushard yes rep McKenzie
yes the clerk votes yes rep Clair yes
rep stab yes Mr chair yes 20 to zero any
objection to consent
agenda seeing none thank
you moving on to House
Bill
1110 relative to e
motion would you like to make that
representative speedi to legisl
represent Presa
McKenzie Al in expedient to
legislate um seconded by representative
stab thank you you recognize to speak to
your
motion I think uh I think Mr chairman
that the verify system has been
controversial um since it was originally
established it is riddled with the with
problems it has improved somewhat but
it's still riddled with problems and I
think the potential of taking somebody
out uh because of a problem with the
system the potential is there and I
don't think it's necessary uh uh to to
move forward with this legislation I
would ask to support the
you I don't any other hands
uh
the the two comments that I hear
repeatedly about this bill uh number one
it's voluntary you can do it now if
you'd like if you're an employer
so have at it uh uh number two another
comment that was made by the employer
was uh why are you making us through the
job of the federal government to verify
whether someone is here uh legally to
work in the uh in the country or not so
uh thirdly obviously um there's been
problems especially if you have a
two letter last name as in some
nationalities do um kind of
sets the system up in a tizzy and you
can have someone that's clearly uh an
American citizen that because of the way
their name is spelled they will get a a
a reject uh
rejection um on their ability to work
and you could go through a two or three
week appeal process to try to get that
resolved when that person is trying to
work and that employer wants to hire
them so if you want to do it yourself
voluntarily
seeing no other comments the motion on
the floor on House Bill 1110 is
inexpedient to legislate it has been
moved and seconded we've had the
discussion if you're in favor of the itl
you'll vote Yes if you're against you'll
vote no Madam clerk please call the role
Vice chair seaworth yes rep avalani yes
rep Prout yes rep c yes rep n yes rep
Mason yes rep kcom yes yes rep drgo yes
rep Granger yes ranking D Sullivan yes
rep Bui yes rep kahill yes rep hacken
Phillips yes rep Susi yes rep Bard yes
rep McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes
repair yes rep stab yes Mr chair yes 20
to
zero there any objection to consent
much I'm just waiting a second here to
the before I start calling the next
appreciate uh
next all right house bill 121 relative
to payments for deceased employees
representative aaland you're recognized
thank thank you Mr chairman I move ought
to pass move by representative alalani
second by
representative
Prout you're recognized to speak to your
motion uh thank you Mr chairman um this
just oh before you I have you do
that
um oh no you go ahead speak to your
motion and then we'll have a report from
the subcommittee or were you he was on
the sub right okay I don't remember were
you the chairman of the subcommittee I
all right represent all right we have
anything to what I I listen I I don't
want individuals that sponsor their own
bills to make the motion in the
committee okay so I've asked
representative avalani to do it we'll
let him make his motion then Brian uh
can speak about it since it was his bill
but that that's the reason I did it so
just so you all know all right thank you
representative balani I will defer my
time to the chairman of the subcommittee
all right represent representative
seaworth you recognized thank you Mr
chairman as indicated um we met in a
subcommittee on this and had some
lengthy discussions in the end um there
was agreement all around that it was
prudent to raise um the the limit for
this which is the amount of money that
an employer can pay
directly um to
the uh Survivor of a deceased employee
um to something that matches what was in
law at the time but we did not think it
was wise to raise it too much because
there are dangers you could get into if
if too much money is being moved around
outside of the the formal process one
question that I asked the department to
answer which they did was beforehand I
didn't understand whether you could only
pay directly if the amount of money owed
was less Le than
$3,000 or if it was more could you pay
up up to the $3,000 and then the rest
went to probate they reviewed the law
and the answer is the second so whatever
is owed to an employee if it's requested
by the spouse of the deceased for
example the employee can issue up to
$3,000 or whatever is owed whichever is
higher and then the rest um takes place
through the the process um
I think I will for the rest of it the
the chairman joined us in the
subcommittee meeting and you made some
excellent points about how probate
actually works and what this money means
in terms of of of the overall process
that I found very Illuminating so before
I mention those representative buard and
Sullivan were also on the committee if
you have any comments represent Sullivan
and if you could pass this to the clerk
for the folder on I I I do there were
ever areas of anxiety that uh we
uncovered during the the lengthy
discussion um and um you
know there were to some degree
alleviated by the fact that um U the the
current language of the of the statute
says that um an employer May pay to the
Survivor um but doesn't have to um and
would would paid to the Survivor if a
proper notice is um given so if there's
no notice they don't pay if they don't
want to they don't pay um so and and
frankly in talking about going through
the um uh the statute on um figuring out
who gets the money um if it goes beyond
the spouse or the kids it get it can get
really complicated and if it goes beyond
the spouse of the kids they probably
need a lawyer to figure it out um and
they might pay more than $3,000 to get
the uh answer so the fact that it's it's
a May was uh um comforting because if it
hadn't been a May inclusion um but I'm
sure that some employers will want to do
this because they care about the uh the
folks who have been left by an employee
who passed um but uh my advice would be
be very careful if it's anything other
than the spouse of the kids because um
you might give the money to the wrong
person I mean worse comes to worse they
they they'll pay $3,000 to somebody and
then pay the $3,000 again to somebody
else um because they paid the wrong
person um but um the uh three $300 was
rid ridiculous um
$3,000 is not too excessive I think if
the number were much higher we would
have been uncomfortable which is why we
just left it with what representative
seaworth initially um proposed um but um
certainly we wouldn't want it a whole
lot higher than that just in case the
wrong people get paid so um but I think
I think as it is um I can certainly
support the a to
pass bushard thank you Mr chair uh I
don't have anything else to add to it so
I I do support what we agreed
upon unfortunately I've been the
executive two Estates um and the
the realistically you know this bill was
uh the this law was first enacted in
1963 um and it was $300 which was
probably an appropriate amount at the
time what really happens when someone
dies unfortunately is um someone that
doesn't have a lot of extra money
hanging around they could utilize that
paycheck if that individual was deceased
because the cost of a
burial the cost of getting an attorney
if you have to because in the state of
New Hampshire you know you have to uh
submit something to probate you have to
pay a probate fee you have to wait for
the judge um you have to get a bond uh
because of the Fairbanks
situation people don't know that 25
years ago a judge in the western part of
the state took off a lot of people's
money and so now every judge puts a
minimum Bond of $33,000 in place because
it's a $100 cost for a bond so uh these
are things that happen when someone dies
and
um when one of the concerns was well
$3,000 what if there's
heirs you know why you give it to maybe
a spouse if there's heirs down the line
they only going to get some money well
realistically by the time you um um
provide burial services that's the first
number one thing in Probate in in
the the rules of who gets what first
first is
burial then it's the
lawyers um then it's the federal
government and taxes and then it's
secured creditors unsecured creditors
and then maybe
bequests to to spouses or relatives or
to children or other relatives so that
$33,000 is probably not going to get
there um to cause that problem um but it
is very important to some that really
need it um when life is chaotic and
someone
representative sorry thank you Mr Mr CH
I plan to support the OTP motion I just
want to point out that this bill would
be unnecessary if we were using hard
money rather than
Fiat noted representative Clair yeah I
also uh will probably votee for the OTP
just wondering um not know if it's a
question or a statement more but um I
understand how the increase works from
300 to 3,000 over the years and just
wondering why um like minimum wage
doesn't get the same look
thank
you second b
d see how we always have fun in this
committee that's always
fun any uh other comments snide remarks
uh funny
jokes okay seeing none the motion's been
made in uh seconded we've had a
discussion it's time for the
roll uh if you are in favor of House
Bill 1201 you you're voting Yes again
you're voting no Madam clerk if you're
Vice chair seaworth yes rep balani yes
rep Prout yes rep c yes rep nter yes rep
Mason yes rep kcom yes rep jgo yes rep
Granger yes ranking Dam Sullivan yes re
Rudy yes rep kahill yes rep hacken
Phillips yes rep Susi yes rep buard yes
rep McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes
wage Warrior lir yes
repir uh rep stab
yes and Mr chair yes 20 to zero any
agenda I'm not going to jinx
it okay we're moving on to house Bill
1246 relative to allowing payments for
wages in gold and silver recognize
representative avalani for a motion
thank you Mr chairman uh I move a to
pass with Amendment
03h you repeat the number I'm sorry yeah
I made a whole bunch of copies are there
does everyone get them are there there
should be about five or six extra around
for anyone who's out in the gallery Ben
if there's some out there on the edge
there okay all right thank you
303h correct motion's been made seconded
Drago represent alalani your thank you
Mr chairman I will defer my time to the
sponsor um is moved by
Drago of grer you're recognized to speak
to your motion thank you Mr chair so
this amendment just makes it impossible
to uh read it in such a way that would
make it mandatory uh needs to be uh
voluntary and recorded as such in
writing by both the employee and the
employer uh this solves a lot of
problems so for instance Municipal and
County government they just don't have
to do it if they don't want to anybody
who doesn't want to get paid in gold and
silver will not be forced to be paid in
gold and silver and um also there was
some concern about the order uh the
reason that it was put in B was uh
because there was uh uh belief that if
it is on the last uh on of the menu then
some of the prior ones would affect it
in some way so U speaking to the people
who had that concern putting it at B
seems nice because we don't want to put
it on a that seems like it's defaulting
to Gold and Silver and if we put it B
it's in the middle and so it gets rid of
that
Sullivan with all due respect I I just
frankly think this uh bill is a bad idea
and um since the bill fundamentally is a
bad idea I'm not going to support an
effort to make a a bad idea less bad so
amendment Aran hains Phils thanks Mr
chair I just I wanted to draw attention
to the subsection B on line 9 and 10
that I think it's unclear whether or not
this is a one-time agreement or it could
be in perpetuity and I think that that
lack of U Clarity causes vagueness which
may cause that sentence to be stricken
from law when it's legally interpreted
if that should ever come up and I think
you know this is a an important concept
to Think Through um before passing um
the actual language that it stands so
for that reason I will be objecting to
the
amendment uh any other
comments you know originally when uh I I
first received the bill
um I looked at it and and and thought in
my mind that that
was wasn't really necessary and and um
then I I having reviewed the motion you
know one of the things that comes down
to some of the things we do here in the
committee um has to do with enabling
legislation and um if if two consenting
individuals on a contract want to engage
in
something
um the question I always have to myself
is why do I think I need to step in the
way and
and say it shouldn't
happen if there's no ability for anyone
to force an employer to do it if there's
no ability for the employee to force the
employer to do it and if I'm am
realistic
to even though my 60-year-old brain
doesn't wrap my head around it very much
when it comes to bitcoin and all this
other stuff that goes on um you know
that that is you know going to be next
um in line of utilizing other mechanisms
you know when again I can't wrap my head
around someone buying a painting online
because it has a what do you call it
Andrew you were laughing what do you
call that
stuff whatever you know what I'm talking
about aft yeah I still don't wrap my
head around that
one thank you so uh but they are they do
exist uh I don't see any harm in this
although I respectfully think it's kind
of goofy I don't see that we've done
anything to harm either the employer or
the employee
uh don't disrespect anyone else who
disagrees with me but that's where I
just want to let you know where the
chairman was coming
from so we have uh a motion on the floor
uh ought to pass the
amendment I'm sorry the amendment was on
the floor my apologies thank
you um moving you want to raise I'll
make it quick since we are voting on the
amendment um I I understand the concerns
of my fellow committee members but I
think it's very important that we not
Advance the original bill um that what
we do bring forward for discussion
purposes has the correction that has
been made for the reasons we discuss
thank
you one last word representative grer uh
if this amendment fails I'll bring it up
then representative kahill thank you Mr
chair sh is is there anything in current
law that prohibits an employer an
employee from agreeing to payment in
gold and silver and platinum and
zirconium I'm going to let you answer
that representative Granger thank you Mr
chair so the fact that it isn't in this
list uh this is a this is a white list
not a black list and so if since we have
a white list of legal ways to pay people
for their bi-weekly or weekly wages then
yes the fact that it's not on this list
legal
okay uh we have the motion is the
amendment is ought to pass on Amendment
03h if you're in favor you vote Yes
oppos vote no madame clerk could you
call the rooll on the amendment Vice
chair seaworth yes rep avalani yes rep
Prout yes rep c yes rep na yes rep Mason
yes rep kcom yes rep drgo yes rep
Granger
yes ranking Dam Sullivan no rep Rudy no
rep Cahill no rep hackin Phillips no rep
Susi no rep buard no Brett McKenzie no
the clerk votes no rep laclair no rep
stab no Mr
fails uh then it's open to further
Amendment and if there's no further
amendments then it goes to um the
bill so I'm waiting for a motion from
one representative Granger I move OTP on
Bill original Bill moves ought to pass
on the original
bill I need a
second
Drago you're off uh you're recognize to
speak to your motion thank you Mr chair
um so the amendment that I brought up
was to clarify the bill but it doesn't
fundamentally change the bill um
whenever you make a contract with people
uh you can write down in in the contract
how you plan to pay people the original
bill without this amendment does
essentially the same thing it just
doesn't stipulate that it must be in
writing uh the concerns that were
brought up that it needs to be in a
specific order uh were not based on
anything uh real it's a list of menu
options it's sort of like if you go to
McDonald's you can get a burger you can
get fries you can get a milkshake the
fact that you're getting a milkshake
doesn't mean that you automatically get
fries so anything that is listed as
another letter item uh doesn't affect
the actual bill um it's a we live in a
state where employment is voluntary um
therefore this amendment is entirely
unnecessary um although I brought it up
because I thought it would uh help
appease certain concerns uh the original
bill is going to accomplish exactly the
same thing so I'm going to support the
OTP motion on the original
bill
represent
seaworth um given my statement just
before that previous vote I don't do not
think that I can uh my concern and I I
don't think I have time to figure it out
definitively on the Fly here but my
concern was down in subsection e and the
references to other sections that that
uses and the way the original bill was
structured I didn't think they cross
reference properly so I'm going to have
to um vote no on this motion and uh
reiterate my support for the the
proposed I see no other comments the
motion on the four is ought to pass
moved in second if you're in favor you
vote Yes if you're opposed you will vote
no Madam Clerk Vice chair seaworth no
rep balani no rep Prout no rep c no rep
nter no rep Mason no rep culcom no rep
Dro yes rep gringer yes ranking D
Sullivan no rep Rudy no rep kill no rep
hackin Phillips no rep Susi no rep bu
no rep McKenzie no clerk votes no repir
no rep St no Mr chair
18 moving on to house bill I think we we
need a motion we need another motion one
that was the motion of ought to pass um
it
failed I apologize
right
sorry Mr chairman yes um in light of the
that
would anyone like to make a motion of an
expedent to legislate representative
Sullivan I move in expedient to
legislate move
by representative uh Susi
seconded if uh recognize to speak to
your
motion I've made my point I don't think
uh paying in gold and silver is a good
idea um paying with a commodity that uh
changes value continuously um is uh
awkward at the very least and impossible
itl repr Granger thank you Mr chair I
oppose the itl because doing business in
a commodity that changes price
frequently is just not very useful and
uh therefore I think we need to switch
to gold and silver thank
you
all
right seeing no other
hands the motion on the floor is
inexpedient to legislate so we moved and
seconded if you are in favor of the
motion you will say yes oppos you'll say
no Madam clerk please call the role Vice
chair seaworth
avalani
no rep Prout no rep c no rep n no rep
Mason yes rep kcom no oh he voted rep
Mason voted yes correct correct and then
R
kcom thank you keeping me on my toes uh
rep
drgo
no rep Granger
no R ranking D Sullivan yes Rett barudi
yes rep kahill yes rep hackin Phillips
yes rep Susi yes Brett bashard
yes
motion yes is itl okay just um I'm sorry
R Mackenzie you voted yes I'm just
clarifying uh the clerk votes yes repli
Clair yes
rep stab
yes Mr chair
to9 the motion passed now
that's I didn't understand it now I
understand
okay
1519 so do we need a Minority Report
yeah
minority yeah no on
solance The Minority Report will have
our
minority well we will have a minority
recommendation which will be
18 correct that's you're and you're
writing
okay right now
to
1519 relative to minor available work
hours recognize representative seaworth
for a
motion I move
itl second chairman motion on the floor
is inexpedient to legislate by
representative C worth it is seconded by
representative alalani representative
seaworth you recognize to speak to your
motion uh thank you Mr chairman um after
we had some lengthy discussions in the
uh in the hearing I had some more
discussions with the Department of Labor
who sent me some answers I had
discussions with the sponsor of the bill
and some other groups that had
concerns and at the end of the day um
I think what's clear is the sponsor
heard some issues from members of the
public that weren't necessarily aligned
with the law so the the way she had
originally proposed the law it it didn't
quite make sense um just in a nutshell
there are very different rules for 16
and 17 year olds for 14 and 15 year olds
and for 12 and 13 year olds and each of
those are different and I think a lot of
times people coming to this for the
first time don't understand the
distinction um in a nutshell if you're
under 16 the federal law is very
explicit and applies and um if you're 16
and 17 most of the regulations fall the
state law which are very different and I
think people get confused sometimes that
their 15-year-old runs into a problem
and they think they look to the state
law and find what we've written for for
an older older team so after all that
discussion the sponsor agrees with me
that um what the bill proposed to do is
neither necessary because what she was
asking for essentially is state law um
or or helpful at this time and if indeed
some members of the public do come to us
with
inconsistencies uh we'd be happy to look
you I see no other hands if any would
like to
speak the motion on the floor is
inexpedient to legislate has been moved
and seconded if you are in favor of the
itail vote you will
signify by saying yes your opposed will
signify by saying no madame clerk please
call the role Vice chair seaworth yes
rep balani yes rep Prout yes rep c yes
rep naer yes rep Mason yes rep
kcom yes rep dreo yes rep gringer yes
rankie D Sullivan yes rep arudi yes rep
Cahill yes rep hackin Phillips yes rep
Susi yes rep Bard yes rep McKenzie yes
the clerk votes yes rep lir yes rep stab
yes and Mr chair yes 20 to zero any
objection to consent
you
House
Bill
1648 relative to electronic pay cards
recognize representative Susi uh
Sullivan for a motion thank you um I
move um in expedient to legislate second
avalani Sullivan you recognized to speak
to your motion thank you um
I think many of
us I won't speak for many of us I'll
speak for myself
um I happen to believe that this um bill
should not have come before us because
it is following a very similar Bill
almost identical bill from last year um
and um and frankly we sh the sponsors
should have uh taken a message from the
vote last year which I believe was
unanimously against the payroll cards um
and um I personally feel as strongly
this year as I did last year that
um the the paper check should still be
available as a manner of payment um not
many people take them it's not an
overwhelming burden to do it and frankly
I get the sense that this bill is here
only because there's a company that's
pushing it um so for that reason um I
have moved itl and um I also understand
that there was a a subcommittee that uh
had a lengthy look at uh um a potential
Amendment but I not going to speak to
that because I was not on that
subcommittee um but my understanding is
that they came to a four to4 agreement
that itl should stand but I would let
them speak to
that thank you the subcommittee was made
up of uh I was avalan uh K Hill Susi and
myself so representative alalani since
you made the uh uh second the motion you
may speak first and then the other two
gentlemen um have your comments after
thank you Mr chairman um Echo
representative cvan's um uh comments um
as well uh we we defeated this bill
silly last year um and it's back again
um the problem as an employer um you're
making employee now request check um the
default payment will be a bank card if
you don't have their uh Bank information
they're removing written
authorization um to allow direct deposit
um and there is one company there isn't
just one company that operates payroll
cards in the state there are others um
and a lot of other ones have fees
associated with uh simple items so at
93% of the population that does direct
deposit um the other 7% could be um
forced into these pay cards with these
fees and um I don't think that's right
also taking away the employer's default
to a check if they can't get any
information from the employee
um you know we shouldn't be telling what
employers or employees should should or
should not be doing in getting their uh
pay unless they have written a contract
thank you Mr
chairman of Susi any representative
kahill you're all set you're waving off
okay one of the things I think is very
important
what that I had learned over my years
here is that we have to think when we
make law about every type of uh
employee whether they're making minimum
wage whether they're
making a lot of
money and also what kind of businesses
we have not everything fits in a nice
simple cookie cutter where you work for
a grocery store or you work for an
insurance company or you work for you
know an airlin or or whatever you do I
don't even know what the heck you do
something things um something to do with
your computer all the time um so um we
have to try to think of everything and
how it fits with these and does it fit
in and right now the law
Works 93% we're told of the people
utilize a direct deposit the remaining
7% of the 750,000 people employed in
this state leaves about 51,000 people
that are either getting a check either
getting a pay card
um pay you know how however whatever
agreements they've made
um we all have to advance with society
and Society is going to pay cards and
debit cards and everything else um but I
have to think about that person who's
working two jobs making you know $10 an
hour each one and the fees associated
with some of these things and one of the
Hallmarks of everything that we've
learned in this committee is that you
earned that that pay you deserve to get
that
pay at a bank convenient to where to
where you're working for no cost and
that's always been the platform that
we've had here and
um If an employer wants to make a deal
with their employees to utilize pay
cards and maybe pay for some of the fees
or provide this now that's still
provided the pay card they can still use
the pay card and go to a certain Bank
get their money um but then there there
are some pay
cards
that only allow you to take so much so
you may not be able to withdraw your
entire
paycheck from that at one point uh we
looked at every single sentence of the
bill and a proposed amendment
um tried to work different
ways there's things in the bill the ex
existing bill which I don't prefer
because it places blame on the employee
here if the system has a
hiccup I don't think it's the employer's
problem with the pay card system has a
hiccup we all know computer systems have
hiccups and anyone lose their cell phone
service last week for a certain couple
cell phone companies anyone on Facebook
I guess yesterday who couldn't couldn't
um
that's
enough that's enough um
so may maybe someday but not the way
this has been
presented I see I see no other hands the
motion of the floor is inexpedient to
legisl has been moved and seconded if
you are in favor of the ined legislate
you will vote Yes if you're against you
will vote no madame clerk if you are
ready you may call the role Vice chair
seaworth yes rep
alalani oh yes rep Pratt yes rep c yes
rep naer yes rep Mason yes rep kcom yes
rep Dro yes rep Greener yes ranking J
Sullivan yep rep Bry Yes again re kahill
yes rep hacken Phillips
yes rep Susi yes rep buard yes rep
McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes repli
Flair yes rep stab yes Mr chair yes 20
to
zero we have no other bills in front of
us
that
what is your
choice you're all set I'm
uh I
objection the regular calendar it's on
the regular
calendar there are no other bills uh
before us we have gone through our our
list of bills assigned to
us I am only aware of one piece of legis
ation coming from the Senate at this
point there will be more um but I'm not
going to um probably pull a a committee
to uh hearings together unless we have
all of our bills we if we have three
four five then we'll pull it together
for one for one session um I would we uh
I need to report these out by next
Thursday I really would like them uh by
the close of business Friday giving you
a couple more days while you're sitting
in your shair listening to debate you
already know how you're going to vote on
tomorrow you can write the blurs and
email it to me if you'd
like uh any other questions comments
questions of the chair any other
committee representative thank you Mr
chairman just for process if we have a
small amount of bills would it be able
for us to execute them on the same day
yes well I'm not a fan of executing
bills the same day we hear them
especially if there's something that
comes up which we all know that someone
says something afterwards we learn
something or what have you depending on
how they come through I'll make that
decision usually with the um
representative Sullivan to to see
whether we do that I I I know want I
don't want to you know if we have four
bills and if they're really simple they
pass through the Senate everyone here is
in favor of them I might agree to doing
so thank you Mr
chairman I I think the current house
rule is that um you can um uh exec on
the same day um with agreement between
the chair and the ranking member um and
I will just share that uh um if if
there's any reason to doubt whether
we've had enough uh time to consider in
debate I I I won't consent I don't think
uh the chair would suggest we should
vote um but uh but basically if if if
we've got a a no-brainer bill and we can
um exec on the same day after you know
carefully considering it um I I
no represent n thank you Mr chairman I
just wanted to commend you for the
efficient way you run your committee
thank
you any other uh comments from anyone
again thank you very much for everyone
being congenial as always so thank you
very much have a good day everyone is
closed you know I didn't want to raise
this as a part of our business but the
gentleman who spoke on behalf of ADP did
not the minority he with the company but
leg well it'll be I'm going to tell you
what I think their opinion
is
ADP ADP is not owns a majority percent
of w but they don't do
pay yes but I think they're
try what happens if I come up
here what happens if I I'm an average JN
will I'm not a legislator I come up here
and speak about an insurance bill
because I have knowledge I'm just a
member of my association should I have a
badge on at that point depends in this
he